good morning Hank it's Tuesday your
video and Friday was really
inspirational because it reminded me
that even after six and a half years of
making YouTube videos there's still room
to do new things and be creative and
we're so lucky because nerdfighters
aren't like gold after doing the old
thing they're willing to change and grow
with us so in that spirit I thought
today I would make a video on my way to
the dentist so that guys you know for
many years I have been the least
educated member of our family you and
the Katherine are both masters of
science the Yeti is a Master of Arts
whereas I am a mere Bachelor of Arts and
that's just not an impressive title at
all Hank because anyone can be a
bachelor all you have to do is be an
unmarried male I mean my three-year-old
son can't read but he's a bachelor but
that's all about to change Hank because
on May 11 thanks to Butler University I
am going to become a doctor specifically
an honorary Doctor I think this means
that if I'm on a plane in the flight
attendant is like is there a doctor on
board I can be like yes oh and if later
tunnel would be like this lady's having
a heart attack and I'll be like well
that's not really in my field I'm an
honorary doctor of letters maybe I could
write her a poem peg the degree I'm
getting is called a deal it or a litter
Arum doctor which I might be
mispronouncing because again the degree
is honorary and it's something called a
higher doctorate because it's
technically a higher degree than a PhD
which of course stands for full doctor
now I know what you're wondering am I
going to lord it over you now that you
are a mere master and I am assumed to be
higher doctor absolutely not Hank as a
doctor I'm humble I'm generous and I
don't judge it turns out that I cannot
call myself a doctor by the way
Wikipedia the only source trusted by
honorary doctors it seems that a few
people over the years have called
themselves doctor after receiving an
honorary Doctorate including noted
inventor and founding father of the
United States Benjamin Franklin who
called himself dr. Franklin after
receiving an honorary degree from the
College of William and Mary in 1758 but
that was the 18th century these days it
is frowned upon to call yourself a
doctor when you have not actually earned
the title also Hank you know the
lexicographer and professional quote
machine dr. Samuel Johnson you know the
guy who said that hell is paved with
good intentions and that patriotism is
the last refuge of the scoundrel who
wrote that a cucumber shall be well
sliced then dressed with pepper and
vinegar and then thrown out as good for
nothing yeah he was just an honorary
doctor I think one more quote from the
great honorary doctor what is written
with
effort is in general read without
pleasure in short a guy will be an
excellent company as an honorary doctor
but I will still just be a mr. last
think I just want to take a second to be
grateful while I am in quite a bit of
like chronic dental pain I am very happy
that the Fault in Our Stars after 15
months of being out has returned to
number one on the New York Times
bestseller list passing my French I call
my friend maybe just acquaintance no
friend my friend Stephen Chbosky the
author of the amazing book perks of
being a wallflower which is now number
two suckage boskie hank dftba i will see
you on Friday